TV network has greenlit a jeselniken
enemy's roast battle where they've
gathered the greatest Roasters in the
world to roast Anthony who would you
pick for your two Roasters to battle
back uh against this here's my here's my
absolute first pick and I would hear
arguments but you'd be wrong I'm gonna
go with Greg Giraldo as my number one
draft pick he always went first on the
roasts always and he had the best set he
destroyed the roast the roast did as
well as they did because of Greg Giraldo
there were there were people who were as
good but no one comes out like him he's
the one everyone was afraid of it was
crazy they had him go first and just
open everything up that he's the guy I
want to have my back uh on a on a rose
if I could pick anyone I want like early
geralda before he was sick of them my
number two pick my final Pick Gilbert
Godfrey I'll never forget that Roseanne
roast uh I was like just physically
trying to survive it physically trying
to survive Gilbert Godfrey just going
off he was incredible I think if I had
Gilbert and Geraldo I don't know who
could [__] with me but you throw me in
there it's it's a [__] it's a big
three